l'europe est en vie à économique et mais
visiblement elle a pris les mesures pour
lutter à armes égales avec nos grands
concurrents chinois les américains les
russes les indiens font leur marché
littéralement en europe 90 % de nos
marchés publics d'ailleurs sont ouverts
à la concurrence extra-européenne quand
c'est 30 ou 40% des marchés américains
qui sont ouverts en chine et en russie
c'est 0% il faut justement se doté
aujourd'hui d'une nouvelle politique de
la concurrence qui nous permettent de
constituer de grands chantiers
industriels de lutter à armes égales et
de s'affranchir de cette naïveté qui
dans le fond et la philosophie de
monsieur macron et de et de son équipe
qui croit au libre échange
j'ai envie de dire au libre échangisme
c'est à dire à cette idéologie qui
consiste à dire que la libre circulation
des hommes des idées des technologies
des capitaux c'est la panacée eh bien
non ça présente des risques
considérables des opportunités aussi
mais que nous peuvent saisir les
entreprises européennes dans cette
guerre oui il faut s'armer
il faut qu'il est naïf faut pas être
paranoïaque faut plus être naïf il faut
surtout se doter des moyens de lutter à
armes égales